there was a beauty pageant that came to
town was not a child who should be
entered in a beauty pageant it was a
Cinderella scholarship pageant I believe
and they I got the brochure and I was
like the I saw in their talent
competition it's very similar he entered
because you wanted to do that where I
think forgive me if I'm wrong but I feel
like a lot of the times it's like I'm
beautiful oh God damn it yes yes
very much like I was surrounded by child
Beauties well Beauties come on and I was
wearing the dress that I wore for my
uncle's wedding I'm dead and like no
teeth and my mom said if I saved up my
money like she would meet me halfway and
if I paid for half she would pay for
half so we did it how much was it
um I don't remember but it enough that
you were enough that I was because I I
think she knew I would embarrass myself
so she was like I'm gonna she was trying
to stop you trying to stop if you can
get
250.
let's go let's go let's go oh [__] this
is terrible but she was my parents are
wildly supportive like if I had told him
I wasn't going into this business I
think they would have been like my dad
as reserved as he is was like there's no
job security and I think he's a CPA like
very by the book
um but had a lot of job losses over the
year from company downsizing so he was
very much like follow your dreams
there's no job security anything which
is amazing that's beautiful by the way
really great one of my favorite lines of
office space where they go They're you
know they're working at in attack and
they don't like it and they go he's
trying to say we need to get out of here
and he goes can you imagine if we're
doing this in 20 years and then one of
the guys goes like it would be awesome
to have that kind of job security and
you realize that there is it's a it's a
myth it's like doing something that
sucks doesn't guarantee you're gonna get
to do it that is so true I forgot about
that one so your dad knew that my dad
knew that so he was very very as with my
mom
um so I did this I did the talent
competition which was me doing
impressions and that was like I'm hooked
I'm a comedian I am and you did all of
it I did yeah I did I mean was there
like walk catwalk oh yeah and I didn't
know like you see me on the video like
just walking around a circle and like
someone be like on this side of the
stage on this side of the stage oh my
God that's how old six or seven six or
seven Rouge pounds yeah I'll see if I
can find it yeah oh my God yes please
this is done no it's not yet not yet not
your moment yes and they and it was like
a weekend like a full weekend like each
day was another so like I like waded
through the like dress wear and then
there was a sportswear and my mom was
like I remember sitting here in the
office just like
so God bless her mortified that I was
going to and but she was also for when
they came time to Talent day she was
like and they didn't really know what I
was going to do your parents are yeah my
parents really I kept on saying I was
going to do Impressions and stand up but
I hadn't really showed it yeah and then
you're like getting a 10-year jump on
Dave Chappelle like I'm six let me do it
um and they and that was it like I
remember like I still remember the
judges and their faces when they were
laughing because I was so because I had
only done sorry it worked it worked and
I won the talent competition of course
he did what was what was number two a
woman shooting an amazing because they
were all like pageant kids like really
great okay so you smoked some some real
guns it was because I was I was and I'm
saying this and not a way to brag it was
so weird what I was doing was so weird I
thought you were gonna say unbearably
cute it stood out though it was weird
like I remember the judges looking at
each other that you get as a kid when
you're old enough to know that people
are
they're not they're like confused by you
yep and I remember seeing that look like
the judges looking at each other and
laughing but being like what is this
what is this and so it really was like a
winning out of this is the weirdest
thing we've ever seen in Suburban New
Jersey and it had to have been good too
I mean what Impressions did you do
started with Mr Furley and everything
was like you're Classic you opened with
the big hip yeah original that was like
my my original joke so it was very much
like
um my next impersonation is going to be
Mr Furley from Three's Company and then
I take a minute
um next impersonation is going to be
um and they it was a lot of just I
remembered the other moms like the faces
on the other moms just like kind of
giggling and I remember that also like
they're not laughing with me
oh like I remember clocking that but
then looking at the judges who are
actually laughing with me and my parents
beaming like that my dad just doubled
over with pure Pride you got all three
you got the laughing in the wrong way
which still hurts my feelings it's not
okay I'm like no really occasionally I
wouldn't I'm not sure about that okay
I'm gonna check myself okay I think I
already wrecked myself but I'm gonna
check myself out of this tracking okay
which a lot of people don't know you can
do you can do it you can check yourself
at any point you can it's nice to do it
before you wreck yourself but even if
you wreck yourself just go ahead and
check yourself hey why did I just wreck
myself you know what I actually think
it's better to do a post check after a
wreck yes right it's the best time to
check after Iraq prereq that's how
you're gonna grow it's like I don't make
kids you don't learn without wrecking no
so until you're 40 go ahead and check
yourself after you wreck yourself I
agree I agree otherwise you're not gonna
you're not gonna learn nothing happens
[Music]